hello everyone
please welcome to today's presentation
in the data analytics stream
scaling data-driven insights across a
complex global organization with looker
and bigquery
in today's presentation we would like to
cover
iron mountain business and technical
drivers
data analytics and visualization
architecture that was established
scalability principles that were in play
gcp products and services that were used
looker value proposition for iron
mountain
challenges and recommendations made
before we get into the details we would
like to introduce ourselves
i am harish karam principal data
architect at spring ml i was the project
manager for this iron mountain project
i have around 25 years of experience
implementing and delivering technology
projects
across many large companies
hi my name is jared garcia i'm the
director of enterprise platforms at
iron mountain i've been with iron
mountain
since december and i've been excited to
join the
iron mountain team to establish a
singular data platform
i would like to give you a quick
introduction to the iron mountain
technical data analytics project
spring ml in partnership with google pso
worked together for
10 weeks this past march and april to
successfully deliver this project
iron mountain provided the program
leadership and smes
spring ml provided the sprint planning
scrum management and implementation
while google pso provided the product
sme
architecture consultation and oversight
i would now like to hand it over to
jared to speak about
iron mountain the initiative that led to
this project
and the current state over to you jared
thanks harish so this is the
typical you know who is iron mountain
slide
um we're a global leader for storage and
information management services
uh we're in 50 countries um and
we service you know a ton of clients
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
here
hopefully you've heard of us and we can
move on to the next slide
um so today what we wanted to talk about
is
the global enterprise the data
platform where
what we're trying to solve is a
localization
problem that iron mountain has had so
we have a lot of different systems
a lot of different countries that we're
working with and each system in each
country has their own way of doing
things
this you know tends to lead to a lot of
repetition as well as a lot of
customization it also gives our
executive team a lot of headaches
because we're not able to
necessarily look at the
company holistically so when we want to
see
a footprint for a particular client it
can take
several weeks for us to be able to
gather all that data
and then be able to present that
information back to our client
the goal of the global data platform
is to be able to centralize all this
over the the project that we began with
google and with spring ml was
geared to get this kicked off what we
wanted to do is to take some of our
operational systems
and land everything into the into
essential data platform
we also then wanted to write a bunch of
different dashboards
and develop uh insights that would
enable
our leadership to have a global
viewpoint
um moving on
so there were three main things as we
talked about our master data
um you know our initiative
one is the technology so you know we're
a google company we love working with
google we love gcp
um we felt that uh bigquery was the
right platform for us
um you know over the
big query has a lot of benefits and uh
harish is going to go over some of those
later on today but
as a platform being able to pull
everything into a central
area and then be able to
utilize bigquery and all the things that
come with it
really is is going to help speed up that
process
the other thing that we had to consider
as well as a governance
policy so what we wanted to do is to
start to set up a data steward
model where we can formalize our
data governance practices so
our idea here is to democratize data and
to make it
readily available to all uh iron
mountain
employees but we do have to you know
consider
uh specific things like you know from a
data
protection standpoint
and then the other part of this is you
know it's it's a big cultural change for
us as well
so um the company wasn't used to kind of
thinking this way
so what we wanted to do is to start to
show
the entire company that you know this
type of thinking uh
the these uh and efforts can happen
quickly and um you know pretty
seamlessly
you know we we adopted an agile mindset
and we were able to start to collect
data from different countries and
different
operational systems and start to land it
into the cloud
and then as well we partnered with you
know spring ml with looker and with
google
in order to build out those dashboards
moving on so
i'm going to jump a little bit ahead
harish is going to go through
all the details about how we got to the
end state
but to give you a preview we were
extremely successful in the project
we have today based off the
success of this project we have 11
different systems feeding our
enterprise data platform we have data
from 56 different countries flowing into
the platform
um and you know it's for us five
terabytes is
is um it's it's a good start
we've only been up and running for about
six months
so we're very happy with the progress
that we're making
um the monstrosity that you see on the
right is kind of a picture that we have
um we're servicing different use cases
as well so we're dealing
you know we're helping our the business
from the record management side from the
data management side
we're working with our colleagues in
infrastructure
within project management and hr to be
able to give them
you know a lot more capabilities than
we've had in the past
so with that i'm going to go ahead and
hand it over back to harish
thanks jared before i delve in deeper
i would like to spend a minute or two
talking about spring ml
we are a premier google cloud partner
and i have delivered over 200 plus
cloud data analytics and visualization
implementations
we have four main capabilities on the
google cloud stream
of our business machine learning and
artificial intelligence
cloud migrations data analytics and
visualization
and application development
as a google cloud partner we have
achieved credentials for
four specializations data analytics
machine learning marketing analytics
and application development
now i would like to delve deeper into
the iron mountain story
i want to talk about iron mountain's
business and technical drivers
for this and future projects
global operations has a requirement to
realize cost savings in record center
operations
there's a need for productivity
monitoring in record centers
across the iron mountain footprint
there's a need for consistency in
building and activity definitions
across countries and operational systems
there's a need for visibility into
facility or building level information
there's a lack of clear insight for
leaders across multiple sites
regions and countries that needs to be
addressed
there are mostly file based processes
with challenges related to file
transfers
there is a monolithic data source skip
with challenges related to reference
data definition
for districts buildings and activities
there are time consuming manual checks
with reference data provided by business
the reports are defined in crystal
reports provision through business
objects
there's a need to standardize reporting
tools
now i would like to talk about the
architecture of the solution we designed
some important features to note are
an on-premise virtual machine to upload
the data extracts
from multiple data sources to google
cloud storage
file upload event based invocation of
google cloud composer dag
upload of data into bigquery staging
tables orchestrated by dag
invocation of sql transformations and
merging of data orchestrated by dag
into bigquery reporting data set
and finally rco reporting dashboard that
we built on looker
which i'll present on the latest slide
the relevant uh scalability principles
in play
for this engagement are
bigquery a highly scalable serverless
data warehouse set up with on-demand
usage and growth
recommendation for automatic scaling of
composer
worker nodes based on usage metrics
and finally an event-driven ingestion
pattern we built
with discussion around moving to message
driven
cloud pops up in future with that
i would like now to talk about the key
gcp products and services we implemented
on this project
google cloud composer for workflow
orchestration that included
processing and loading files into tables
and running sql transformations and
merge queries
bigquery for loading querying and
analyzing large amount
of data cost effectively
google storage for staging and archiving
of file extracts in csv formats
facilitating future retrieval if
necessary
google operations are stack driver for
logging monitoring
and alerting activities of the ingestion
pipeline
and finally delivering insights reports
and dashboards using looker
i would like to spend a few minutes
talking about business intelligence
platform
looker and how it benefited iron
mountain
implementing looker helped us quickly
deliver insights
and enable real-time analytics in a
matter of two to three weeks
it helped us implement governance and
data integrity
by limiting table access data access
masking specific columns and auditing
having the self-service feature enabled
the business analysts
to ask new questions about the data that
is readily available
and to troubleshoot problematic
indicators with iron mountain
operations
and most importantly looker leverages
the gcp investment by
iron mountain it basically leverages
bigquery natively to perform all the
queries
what i am now presenting is the record
center operations dashboard
that we developed for iron mountain
some of the insights the dashboard
enables are
the ability to investigate dip each dip
in
achievement percentage by drilling to
specific country
and district and down to the warehouse
collaborate with country managers to
identify specific
bottlenecks and take specific actions
to bolster the workforce or take
corrective actions within the same day
ability to explore the data and ask
additional questions
especially why some buildings are
reporting high overtime hours
for example
setup alerts when achievement thresholds
are not met so quick action can be
initiated
some of the challenges we found and the
recommendations we were able to provide
are agreeing upon data formats
business logic and structure ahead of
time to minimize re-engineering
continue to develop a devops culture for
maximum
scalability and portability by
leveraging terraform
for automated deployments and building a
cicd
pipeline for efficient core deployments
data cleansing is best done upstream
near the source of the data
to minimize complexity in coding logic
review architectural decisions
constantly and optimize
to implement the right fit for example
cloud data flow was determined to be an
overkill for the simple transformations
we switched to using bq load as there
were minimal or no sql transformations
or the parallel processing wasn't needed
identified growth opportunities we
recommended improved security monitoring
firewall logs alerts and so on
fault resolution and performance
management of
for for future projects
finally i would like to close out with
the project outcomes we were able to
achieve
we completed proof of concept to ingest
data from iron mountain systems
to bigquery for data analysis
we enabled enterprise data warehouse
modernization and reporting through data
democratization
enabled near real-time handling of data
ingestion
and on-demand visualization
helped reduce different tools being used
at iron mountain to reduce
copying of data sets
enabled iron mountain for success by
beginning to create
a unified gcp standard across the
organization
and established an infrastructure
baseline
for future data ingestion and
visualization projects
this concludes our presentation thank
you
thanks everyone